ils viennent de terminer leur mission du
jour l'ouverture du défilé aérien du 14
juillet comme chaque année les neuf
pilotes de la patrouille de france lâche
la fumée tricolore au dessus des champs
elysées une édition 2021 au départ de la
base sans cesse de vélizy villacoublay
d'où la patrouille de france a décollé à
10 heures précises au super bowl était
plutôt bonne finalement et on est passé
à l'heure à trois secondes à trois
secondes et aisément travaux très bonne
visibilité puis des plafonds net ça
s'est déroulé comme prévu formation le
timing la météo était bonne c'était
parfait c'est toujours un grand honneur
et une grande satisfaction que direct le
défilé sur le 14 juillet d'ouvrir
surtout le défilé du 14
pour cette édition la paf arborer des
dérives avec la tête d'antoine de
saint-exupéry un hommage aux 75 ans de
la publication du petit prince
directement sur les avions des alphajet
scrutées par les mécaniciens de la
patrouille de france
ils sont une quarantaine comme le
sergent chef jérémie je faire
l'entretien de l'avion m'assurer que les
pages de dégâts pendant le vol par
exemple une prison volatile avec un
oiseau je m'assure l'équipe à deux de
fuite hydraulique
kippen pana particulière je regardais le
moteur oui effectivement pour françois
qui a pas eu de suites tuiles que les
niveaux surfer autres appareils au
départ de la base de vélizy-villacoublay
les hélicoptères fennec de l'armée de
l'air et de l'espace
des aéronefs utilisés sur plusieurs
missions polyvalente
ils étaient deux à défiler au dessus des
champs elysées l'un d'entre eux était
piloté par le capitaine armes
c'est un moment de convivialité pour
nous l'hélicoptériste de l'armée de
l'air et de l'espace pour se retrouver
et après en plus de ça effectivement
voilà c'est tout un symbole c'est le
défilé du 14 juillet voilà c'est montrer
qu'on est fiers de notre nation montrer
les compétences qu'on a deux autres
hélicoptères fennec était dans le ciel
de paris le 14 juillet leur mission
assurer la défense aérienne du défilé en
formant une bulle de protection autour
du site
objectif éviter l'intrusion d'aéronefs
dans le périmètre
on va s'approcher justement de l'aéronef
et on va lui faire un message en fait on
a un panneau lumineux où on peut écrire
des messages sans relâche pas être en
communication avec donc on lui demande m
on met une fréquence radio on lui
demande de se mettre à cette fréquence
pour pouvoir communiquer écrit souvent
défaillant en a deux aéronefs qui ont
des problèmes radio donc ils ont plus de
communication du tout donc par exemple
on peut lui m suivez nous donc faut au
milieu ou suivez nous hélas à partir de
ce moment là on va l'emmener sur un
petit aérodrome ou occupés se poser
sereinement
au total 97 avions et hélicoptères ont
participé au défilé du 14 juillet 2021